[Musique]
et cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
patrick chauvel bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être sur ce plateau photographe de
guerre à porter de guerre c'est ainsi
que vous aimez vous présentez vous avez
fait en 1992 la couverture du premier
numéro de l'album de reporters sans
frontières c'est à votre travail que
rend hommage le dernier numéro qui est
sorti au mois de mars et qui hélas sont
photos pour la liberté de la presse la
liberté de la presse que l'on célèbre
aujourd'hui ce mardi 3 mai patrick
chauvel votre vie n'est pas une myriade
de chiffres mais tout de même 50 ans de
carrière plus de 34 guerre est une
mission encore il ya quelques semaines
en ukraine on va y revenir albert
londres notre maître à penser à tous
disaient qu'il fallait porter la plume
dans la plaie vous l'appelez vous la
photographier oui la photographie je
suis aussi des documentaires les pays
après écrire des livres c'est aussi
continuer les reportages donc moi c'est
la passion c'est de raconter ce que je
voie d'être un peu la voix des gens qui
peuvent pas nous parler parce qu'ils
sont loin ou qui peuvent pas voyager ou
qui sont des situations de guerre et à
travers ce cet album café à l'essai
fonds continue de raconter l'histoire en
ouvrant les pages au fur et à mesure
vous on se rappelle que ce qui s'est
passé ou ce qui se passe encore en
tchétchénie ou ailleurs et donc on
arrête jamais en fait quelques-unes des
photos de cet album défilent derrière
nous cette envie de terrain patrick
chauvel chez venu à des venu très jeune
vous aviez même pas vingt ans vous êtes
à les couvrir la guerre des six-jours
vous dit qu'à cette époque là les photos
d'air que vous en avez rapporté
pas dingue vous dites qu'au début la
photo en fait c'était le prétexte vous
ce que vous vouliez c'était aller sur le
terrain au début c'était le goût de
l'aventuré mais j'ai bon j'avais quand
même mon cas a été grand reporter jean
françois chauvel il était au figaro mon
grand père était diplomate il a
participé aux accords de genève donc
l'histoire hélas l'histoire avec un
grand h leurs copains ces jeux joseph
kessel pierre schoendoerffer
l'article qui donc cédé que des gens qui
racontent des histoires incroyables qui
les vivent et qui les raconte bien c'est
leur métier donc à amender on peut tuer
le père donc on veut faire mieux donc je
suis allé voir je leur ai demandé je
leur ai dit que je voulais aller au
vietnam ils m'ont dit vas-y on va voir
ce que tu as dans le ventre alors
effectivement au début c'est une
aventure personnelle
on aimerait que les soldats américains
au vietnam en hélicoptère etc et puis un
jour on on a un témoignage moi j'ai eu
le témoignage d'un la commissaire
politique
nord-vietnamiens qui va ils étaient
prisonniers des américains il m'a parlé
de son combat alors ils m'agacent est un
peu parce qu'il lui avait tiré dessus
juste avant mais ça m'a troublé quand
même je sentais que ça cause avait de
bonnes raisons aussi aller et d'un seul
coup j'étais moins pote avec les
américains pas forcément pâte avec lui
je suis senti un peu seul et est devenue
juriste ça est sale el sol parce que
normalement participe pas on n'est pas
avec on est avec les gens pour les
écouter mais on doit rester impartial
c'est dur c'est difficile on a nos idées
mais on doit faudra fait ce qu'on voit
et on doit faire attention à être
essayer d'être au milieu si possible
c'est impossible mais on va dire que
l'idée c'est ça au service bien sûr du
média pour lequel on travaille mais
surtout de la vérité en tout cas du
temps des puits de l'histoire quelque
chose de plus grand que nous oui puis
c'est pas moi qui les lie à la première
victime de la guerre est la vérité notre
notre rôle c d'ici là de la trouver de
gratter de chercher et un soir j'ai
rencontre j'ai vu adrien jaulmes qui
revient du crel c'est compliqué de
travailler là bas parce qu'en plus les
ukrainiens
évidemment sur les agresser mais ils ont
du mal à laisser la presse travailler
c'est une armée disciplinée qui se méfie
des appareils photo des caméras des
téléphones portables à forte raison
d'ailleurs et il ya aussi tous
d'ailleurs eu toute une on va dire une
génération joe wright qui twitte
j'aimerais bien leur dire d'arrêter de
tweets et parce que c'est dangereux on
n'a pas besoin de dire à notre copine de
ce qu'on fait quand on est en ukraine et
ou à nos amis sur facebook pour être
admiré c'est normalement on est là le
journaliste c'est voir sans être vu et
pas tout le temps parler de soi
là pour parler des autres et le tweet
c'est dangereux parce que ça va donner
votre position et riches peuvent
bombarder d'eau est vous êtes allé en
ukraine il ya quelques semaines je
travaille pas en secret en disant que
vous avez 73 ans aujourd'hui patrick
chauvel pourquoi vous aviez besoin
encore d'y aller d'aller au plus près
c'est une guerre très importante qu
on est en train d'assister à un
changement d'époque c'est la plus la
guerre la plus importante depuis la
guerre de corée on va dire depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale ensuite la
guerre de corée c'est la première fois
dans toute ma carrière que je vois des
navires de ce tonnage couler des avions
des deux côtés des chars des deux côtés
d artillerie lourde des deux côtés des
missiles et deux côtés à face et c'est
une guerre qui peut devenir la troisième
guerre mondiale si ce n'est déjà fait ce
qu'en fait on est en guerre contre les
russes on ne le dit pas mais quand à
partir on envoie des canons caesar des
en ukraine et que les américains
envoient des chars et des missiles anti
chars etc on se bat contre les russes
dont vous le dit pas mais c'est nos
armes quand même parce que ce que dit le
reportage de guerre a contrario c'est le
miracle de la démocratie par ailleurs et
de la paix oui si on veut en tout cas il
faut contrer
les russes en ce moment qui se sait pas
ce qui s'est passé je sais pas pourquoi
outin d'un seul coup décident d'envahir
l'ukraine oui évidemment il a peur de la
démocratisation de la région il appert
l'otan mais tout est faux toutes les
informations données en russie sont
fausses au début moi j'ai voulu partir
j'avais demandé à paris-match deux
parties en russie d'ailleurs on avait
obtenu avec les limites blachère la
journaliste de match des visas presse
russes
l'idée c'était trois mois avant le
conflit c'était de montrer le
patriotisme russe était en marche et je
vous rappelle j'avais dit aux gens de
match il prépare son peuple à la guerre
il va le faire et en fait au moment où
on est parti ça a pris plus de trois
semaines pour avoir ce visa
ça a commencé à taper en ukraine donc on
l'a changé de direction donc c'est pas
pu faire sur un portage sur le
patriotisme le russe fait il ya quand
même la cathédrale de l'armée
il ya des vitraux avec staline poutine
il ya des tranchées autour pour exercer
les mots combat il préparait son pays
regehr et les soldats quand
l'intervieweur lesquels il y en a qui
avait 19 ans c'est un nicolas delesalle
de paris match qui a attribué le type il
avait 19 ans il savait pas qu'il était
en ukraine
donc c'est le moral de l'armée russe
peut pas être bon sur les soldats sont
même sont pas motivés ne savent pas
pourquoi ils sont là alors que le moral
des ukrainiens excellent
vous avez couvert beaucoup de conflits
on le disait vietnam cambodge au boss
tiers égaux vincini irak irlande du nord
salvador je voudrais qu'on revienne sur
peut-être le siège de sarajevo qui a été
un moment particulier dans l'histoire de
l'europe d'ailleurs on dit que la guerre
avec l'ukraine est revenu en europe en
réalité le siège de sarajevo
en était une bien sûr avec sa douleur
est ce que vous diriez vous avez vu des
choses en ukraine dernièrement que vous
aviez vu déjà à l'époque à sarajevo dans
ce que pensent qu'en sièges peut faire à
une société humaine notamment non parce
que ça n'a pas duré aussi longtemps le
siège de sarajevo faut pas l'oublier
c'est le plus long siège de l'époque
moderne
ça a duré plus de trois ans quand même
et et sarajevo le front était partout
parce que les armes étaient sur les
collines au dessus donc il y avait un
front et vêtements le de confrontation
mais les snipers servez les mortiers
servent et les cadeaux on cerne pouvez
taper la ville à n'importe quel endroit
à kiev oui
mario paul louis marie gopaul c'est
totalement détruit après l'avoir
sarajevo était énormément vous regardez
mes passes voilà la seule ville que j'ai
connus bombardé comme ça c'était grozny
encore une fois les russes dire qu'ils
leur méthode c'est de tout aplatir et
ensuite d'avancé avec l'armée les chars
mais ça marche pas vous raconter qu'il
vous a fallu longtemps en fait des
allers retours entre l'actualité votre
carrière mais pour accepter quand vous
reveniez de mission que la vie ailleurs
se poursuivre qu'il fallait s'adapter à
l'indifférence comme on fait ça on
repart en fait on s'adapte à
l'indifférence il faut essayer de nom
peut pas rester parce qu'il faut d'abord
parce que les conflits se suivent ça
n'arrête pas la sécurité de l'emploi si
l'on peut dire c'est ça l'art atteint
chaque fois je me dis voilà je vais
passer un petit peu de temps et j'ai un
coup de fil hood est ce que souvent on
voit plusieurs fois dans les mêmes pays
donc j'ai un commandant ou un civil qui
va m'appeler en 10 ans et ça y est c'est
reparti
l'enfant non parce qu'à chaque fois que
ce soit sur un conflit où dans le monde
de la paix il ya des gens formidables et
dans un conflit a des gens qui se
battent pour des causes qu'elle y croit
sur pas forcément la mienne et le
courage l'abnégation le l'envi de ce
prêt à se sacrifier pour leurs idées moi
ça me rassure que des gens qui soient
capables de faire ça
les journalistes quasiment toujours été
tué sur les terrains de guerre mais ce
que vous diriez que au début de votre
carrière par exemple au vietnam au
cambodge qu'ils étaient des victimes
collatérales des combats quand
aujourd'hui ils sont devenus des cibles
bien sûr qu'on est devenus des cibles
mais d'une certaine manière ça prouve
qu'on sert à quelque chose sans ça
pourquoi on essaierait de nous tuer ou
nous bloquer et justement cet album rsf
ça sert à ça c'était avec l'argent
qu'ils récoltaient avec les ventes de
cet album sert à aider les familles à
trouver des avocats à financer des
voyages d affaires venir des gens en
sont rsf s'occupe de quatre journalistes
afghans que j'ai rencontrés quand j'ai
fait un reportage là bas
juste après la chute de kaboul voilà on
est allé on les a rencontrés en douce il
se planquer dans la montagne se
condamner à mort par les talibans ils
ont ici à sortir ils sont bloqués en
iran en ce moment rsf fait des pieds et
des mains pour essayer de les sortir de
là il les a menés en france c'est à ça
que sert rsf et le fixeur que j'avais
qui nous a aidés avec nicolas delesalle
quand on était apparu jay a été tué
caméramans le photographe ukrainien
journalistes un garçon formidable et il
a été tué juste après avoir travaillé
avec nous là aussi rsf essayer de faire
une enquête pour savoir comment il a été
tué par les russes pourquoi les russes
l'ont tué moi quand je vais retourner en
ukraine vous allez attendre ouais c'est
sûr j'ai proposé à rsf d'aller dans le
retrouver l'endroit où il a été tué
essayer de comprendre ce qui s'est passé
ce qu'il est il avait un gilet
pare-balles clairement marqué presse
j'ai fait une interview de lui dans la
voiture quand ont foncé dans le combat
sont on était dans sa voiture et m'a
donné pour rigoler je lui ai demandé ce
qu'ils faisaient on faisait connaissance
et avec j'ai toujours une go pro je
filme et c'est un espèce de carnet de
route oui m'expliquer pourquoi il y il
fait ce métier pour près du prêt à
prendre des risques et c est en fait à
amender on l'a perdue parce que quand il
a su que sa cape et à kiev il a dit il
faut que je protège ma famille et je
reviendrai être avec vous après et par
des noms il a été tué vous dites que
quand vous avez dit à votre père que
vous vouliez faire ce métier vous a dit
deux choses d'abord vous auriez tout va
vite des problèmes d'argent vous dites
que vous avez été riche d'autres choses
et que la reconnaissance c'était pour
les journalistes morts
est-ce que cet album est le fait qu on
parle tant de vos photos c'est le signe
qu'il s'était trompé d'une certaine
façon ah oui
on est en vie notre époque c'est une
époque qu'ils connaissaient pas entre
les informations en vite la presse est
mis en avant pour défendre la presse
malheureusement le malheureux points
sont là aujourd'hui c'est les réseaux
sociaux je suis pas contre les réseaux
sociaux mais il faut faire attention
elle est très critique à la presse aussi
s comme ses terrils est une façon à les
coresponsables des critiques quand on y
apporte bah je sais pas il faudrait
demander un effectivement il ya beaucoup
de confrères par exemple en ukraine sont
pas tous professionnels il travaille
beaucoup avec des réseaux sociaux avec
leur téléphone portable
ça rend les soldats écrit nerveux nous
aussi parce que quelquefois ils
balancent des informations qui sont pas
vérifiées
et du coup à partir du moment où il ya
des informations qui circulent dans tous
les sens
les gens finissent par se méfier de nous
il ya aussi des gens qui regardent que
les réseaux sociaux il ya rien de
vérifier sur les réseaux sociaux aux
paras comptait absolument n'importe quoi
l'autre jour j'ai vu des photos de
cadavres alors dit que tant l'ukraine on
a vérifié c'était au mexique très des
vérifications et ça c'est pas fait part
par l'examen et le problème c'est qu'on
ait doublé à droite et à gauche par les
eaux sociaux et du coup les gens ne lis
plus les journaux et regarde sur leur
téléphone vous n'avez pas dé patrick
chauvel à votre métier vous je peux pas
lui dire de choisir un autre métier
voilà antoine chauvet l'a suivi sur
quelques reportages et les partis seuls
aussi mais là pour le coup ce qu'a dit
mon père est vrai il faudra enfin
dépendants
il n'a pas d'argent c'est difficile donc
il fait un autre métier quand il a de
l'argent ils essaient de partir sur un
portable en ce moment il n'y arrive pas
il est allé en ukraine mais il n'a pas
trouvé de journaux pour le supporter est
là il est rentré
faute d'argent en fait et c'est un
métier on le fait pas pour l'argent
enfin il y aurait et un minimum mais
d'après ce malade donc beaucoup de
journalistes et de photographes
maintenant
l'argent il est passé du papier au mur
cercle et il pense galerie pense expo
ils pensent livre il pense tirages
numérotés ça c'est un peu dangereux
parce que c'est pas le support naturel
de
notre métier de raconter c'est pas votre
propos en tout cas donc on peut
retrouver quelques-unes des quads
dizaines de milliers de photos vous avez
pris ce long de votre carrière dans ce
magnifique album donc de reporters sans
frontières patrick chauvel 100 photos
pour la liberté de la presse qui est
sorti au mois de mars mais qu'on peut
encore trouver en librairie on a une
pensée évidemment aujourd'hui
particulière pour notre confrère olivier
dubois et tous les journalistes dans le
monde qui sont emprisonnés en forme et
n'est pas un délit il ne le sera jamais
merci beaucoup patrick je vais lui
mettre ce matin sur le plateau de paray
direct